[Music]
sean is in grand rapids michigan hey
sean welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey anthony hey what's up man
um not much i'm just wondering
so i'm on baby step four i guess
um and what the only reason i say i
guess is because
um look because i've completed steps one
two and three
okay but i just don't know like how
interested i am at actually saving for
retirement
because i don't know if i could ever
like envision myself
actually retiring
i'm so confused right now um how old are
you right now sean
i'm 25 how old will you be next year
26 in february okay so
do you see where i'm going here yeah
so you're saying you're getting older
yeah
so um and i get you i know that
yeah and i get you let me let me let
i probably started out that offroad and
got dave started i'm sorry
no
25 years old are you not motivated to
start thinking about your future hey
let's try this what if we change the
word
from retirement to rich i like that word
i mean i really like the sound of that
too it's the same thing dude
yeah i understand that but i just really
enjoy
working me too i don't i plan to work
until i die a matter of fact i'm going
to stay around here and just spread hate
and dissension in this building oh no
you're not well i certainly hope so
old and old and dementia crept in and
i'll just not be making sense on the air
and james i'll have to be hitting the
dump button
no
and this is what i'm thinking like at
that point like say i were
to go out of my mind like dementia
like cannot can physically not work
anymore
um couldn't i just have money in the
bank
to be able to take care of that yeah the
problem is the bank
pays crap yes like two percent no and i
yeah
so let's pretend let's pretend that you
retire you reach an old age whatever you
want to call old at 25 years old
i'm 60 so old now is a lot older than it
used to be
so but if let's just pretend you reach
old age
and you either have a million dollars
or you don't right
one life is better than the other one
yeah
then you make choices about whether you
want to work or not work
dude i haven't had to work in years
right
i've had financial peace a long time
yeah
i work when i want to work i love what
you're doing yeah
and so you do the same thing man build
you up some wealth
and so i think what you're confusing is
is that you think you have to sit on a
dock and fish
at 55 years old and maybe catch a fish
and just get a sunburn
and you call that retirement retirement
to us means you've got a huge pile of
money
and you could spend the next 30 years
giving it giving it away
and never have given it all away because
the pile was so huge
yeah yeah yeah and i think he says you
know sean i really want you to think
about your future
you're thinking about 55 what if you
could retire at 45
what do you what if you could be like
dave and myself because you know
i'm in financial peace i don't work i
actually enjoy doing what i do with dave
and our team here this is not a nine to
five like i got to get up and have to go
do this
this is i love helping people what if
that could be you at 35
at 45 but you have to start practicing
these principles now
yeah okay and and listen the
a million dollars in your mutual funds
at retirement is not a lot
but it gives you a lot more choices than
not having any money
at retirement and depending on the
government for social insecurity yes
and so you do not want the mantra of
your life to go
i'm going to work all my life and hope
the government which is well known for
its ability to handle money will take
care of me
that's not a good plan so yeah you need
the point is not retirement the point is
build wealth yeah
that's it that's the point so just
change your vernacular on it change your
verbage on it yes and maybe that'll
change the way you're looking at it now
how do we build wealth the most
efficient way to build wealth
is in tax free growth
which happens to be in this thing called
a retirement plan yes a roth
yes but that's the most efficient way to
build wealth yes
keep the government's freaking hands off
your money absolutely
and that you know or by paid for real
estate which then it grows
without any taxes on the growth until
you sell it capital gains growth is not
taxable
it's realized but not recognized under
tax law and so you can do stuff like
that but become wealthy
so that you can not only live your best
life
not only be outrageously generous to
others
but someday you might have a family and
you actually want to change
your family tree the bible says a good
man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children
now that's what we're talking about dave
now i'm getting legacy legacy
that's that's that's this is not
retirement this is a
money it's wealth yeah yeah and so it
happens to be
that the most the first steps to
becoming wealthy and the most tax
efficient investments are those inside
of
retirement plans but if we just take the
word retirement off of and call
this is the best way to get rich yeah
yeah then it changes your mindset maybe
and and dave you know i i want to i want
to i want to i want to say right there
with you because
you've taught me so much from joining
your team and really just learning from
you watching what you do for your family
here's another reason why i'm always
recommending to millennials so think
about
rich think about wealth towards
retirement not just towards
retirement because what can you leave
down to your children's children
steve harvey was on the show with oprah
winfrey a while back and
he was telling the story of how his uh
great great grandmother
was passing away and she asked steve she
said steve do you know your great
grandfather's name
he said no she said do you know why and
he said no she said because he didn't
leave you anything
and that shook me when i was watching
drop and i said
i don't want to die and my children's
children
don't even know my name yeah i mean the
vanderbilt's no cornelius
[Laughter]
you know i mean really let's be real i
got a picture of the
of the commodore over there that come
over the mantle baby you know and when i
look at you
your your grandchildren's children will
know your name
and i went to oh i stirred up a ruckus
you did and i helped i helped you build
it well we helped you build it
and so we are you know that's for me is
that's why you know i
i want my grandchildren and i i wrote a
vow to my kids
i said hey the idea is not wealth for
wealth's sake money just to pile it up
that's mental illness there you go dave
okay but the
money's only good for a couple things
yes sir give it yes sir
enjoy it yes sir and and have long-term
eternal impact including the changing of
your family tree there you go
and so when you can take some money and
reach over and change the destiny of
somebody's life
change the direction the trajectory of
someone's life and they might actually
akin to you
yes sir like your great grandbabies yes
sir then money has had a value at that
point there you go but just piling it up
to say i'm rich nobody i mean that's
shallow yeah
nobody gives a crap what car you drive
that's true shallow
shallow girl wants to date you for what
car you drive
don't let her go come on now be
impactful for your future not impressive
all right this is the dave ramsey show